Once, the United States was filled with beavers.
Up to 250 million beaver ponds
once puddled the continent — that’s enough water to
submerge Washington, Oregon, and California.
But by the beginning of the 20th century,
after decades of over trapping by fur traders,
just 100,000 beavers survived.
The slaughter transformed North America’s waterways.
Beaver activity
-- building dams and forming ponds and wetlands --
slows the flow of water, captures sediment,
and reduces erosion,
After beavers and their speed bumps disappeared,
thousands of streams straightened
and deepened into gullies.
Many streams stopped spilling onto their floodplains
preventing them from recharging water tables.
Some streams dried up altogether.
Now researchers are attempting to “re-beaver”
these run-down valleys with Beaver Dam Analogs
or BDAs.
A row of peeled logs form its frame;
a lattice of woven willow sticks comprise its body.
BDAs provide powerful recruitment tools,
starter kits that offer similar services as
natural beaver dams
while also helping the paddle-tailed engineers
settle where they’re most needed.
Between 2009 and 2012, researchers installed
121 Beaver Dam Analogues along Bridge Creek,
a 45-kilometer long stream
within Oregon’s Columbia River basin.
The goal was to convert a drastically simplified stream
into a complex one.
Sure enough, wherever they put structures,
beavers came and set up shop,
By 2013, beavers had built 115 new dams
and fortified nearly 60 BDAs.
And with the beavers, came results -
as the streambed rose, water coursed once more
on to the floodplain, tripling the creek’s
submerged area and increasing side channels
by over 1200 percent.
In Wyoming,
BDAs are creating wet meadows for sage grouse;
in Utah, they’re sub-irrigating cattle pastures;
in Oregon, they’re rebuilding eroded salmon streams.
For all that momentum, however,
Beaver Dam Analogs continue to hit snags.
Many landowners, as well as some agencies,
still consider beavers tree-felling, field-flooding,
ditch-clogging nuisances, and look askance
on any effort that invites their colonization.
Last year alone, the U.S. Department of Agriculture
trapped more than 23,000 beavers.
But the idea is slowly taking hold -
ranchers in California’s Scott Valley Watershed are
warming up to beavers and their human imitators,
persuaded by water tables that have risen
by as much as three feet and reduced irrigation costs.
Happily, beavers have returned to countless
North American waterways to lend a helping hand...
or paw.